[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
emergency
chat we have issues we have issues I
don't have access to Twitter I can't get
anyone in here has anyone got a logical
way of doing this huh I'm looking at the
chat I know ain't nothing out there
usually I have it all looking all nice
before we get on here but I'm having
emergency issues right now
oh there you go uh dirt dirt are you
comfortable with putting your email in
that chat if you are
perfectly understandable if not text it
to me
no the whole thing's down I try to tweet
you guys to hold things down it's not
just that the whole thing's down
on football webcam
we have guys and King coming through
guys guys and King
bam well let me just take off this
screen
all right
let me blow it up all right there we go
King are you there
okay why
talking
all right talk again
can you guys hear King
I really gotta sit here one day and like
really think about how this stuff's
working
I I sent you the invite it says you're
in
here come back King I'm gonna
come back
a glitch come back King
foreign
there's yours King
yeah we're still doing this guys
um
I need your
I need people to gas and dirt if you
guys are comfortable with your emails
being in the chat tell me if not I'm
gonna have to get you uh you're gonna
have to text it to me
I I don't get it
it stream Labs down too like they're not
I'm not seeing your camera King
all right there we go I can hear you
know
[Music]
oh Discord yes yes everyone send me I
will send you a link through Discord I
forgot Discord existed
thank you
[Music]
there
I hear you in the background King
man
it's gonna be late guys
foreign
[Music]
yeah I hear you
this is
there is a duplicate going on somewhere
and I can't find it
oh wow
all right guys um
add me on Twitter I mean uh
on Discord
foreign
just give you the link here okay
hello everyone I'm Sheena Takahashi and
I'll be your guide for today's Nintendo
Direct
that was the latest trailer for Pikmin
4.
King you still there
King what kind
of please look forward to more
information in the future okay
yes I am oh yes we're echoing off you
it's fine though I just need to make
sure
new hero is a real gem
introducing volume 3 of the Xenoblade
Chronicles 3 expansion pass DLC
I don't know why
all right Dirk guys your your links are
out
we win you'll learn more Heroes and
special abilities
rack up victories With Your Heroes and
set your sights on the final stage
you might also get special in-game
outfits as a reward
coming in volume 4 later this year
tell me why
why nothing's gonna get through to him
he's a heartless machine
[Music]
that killing Granddad wasn't enough for
you volume 3 of the Xenoblade Chronicles
3 expansion pass for the Xenoblade
Chronicle 3 game launches man it just
started relaxed guys it's 40 minutes
long
it's not my fault Twitter went down
I have no clue what's going on with your
uh
your headset King
controllers and gently shake them like
Maracas to match the targets during a
song
yo yeah I can hear you can you see me
you need to change the mic input at the
bottom
is uh
Arrow next to the mute button
s
[Music]
I
can't I couldn't help but Twitter was
down
how's your day
um foreign
now it's weird
I don't know why they can't hear me
oh [__]
[Music]
King said he loves me still after
neglecting me for three years
I don't understand what's going on it
was working
an addicts hear us
I think your mic has an echo he says
mine mine doesn't something on your end
[Music]
all right what about now can you hear me
now
yes I can hear you put in the chat I can
hear them I don't know what's going on
this is the first time this has ever
messed up like this no one's camera's
working
I'm gonna drop kick your ass
not hard he says because he never does
it himself
oh I can see dirt
51 Songs
nah you're still echoing on the stream
by the way
tell them I'm sending them Zoom links
because clearly something's wrong with
streamlabs which will impact your
journey and the entire server
[Music]
I'm gonna go allowed it's just like the
other breads just got Echo within us
hide YouTube together
segregated what is this what is this
what they're showing
what's this game man you guys don't need
to hear the audio for this
zoomy
I didn't come back to work
Zoom meetings and [__] I should get my
tie out
[Music]
yeah
with it
I didn't get a link oh God
foreign
I don't understand why I'm hearing
echoing [__]
laying back
I'm gonna miss the show bruh
I didn't watch anything yet to be honest
it doesn't look like they showed much
they showed um
yes deep
deep dude sorry my bad
[Music]
what about now
how are you how are you nuclear as well
I think we're all working we can't see
your face though
nope I hear it on the stream we bourbon
bro
together in battle as well yeah we're
using Zoom dirt I don't know what's
going on with stream lives there's an
echo that shouldn't be an echo where the
echo's coming from I sound fine now
like five games but they all look the
same yeah
did we miss anything good job no yeah
Pikmin we did not miss anything we
missed pigment I like Pikmin man Pikmin
is dope okay yeah oh look at us he said
hey
he came down on the ship and stuff I was
like what the hell is going on
Pikmin only has one world bro
[Laughter]
can y'all hear me now yep oh geek thank
you brother
I was uh checking for your um for your
email
because I was gonna email you but he was
already in there like what the hell's
going on with Twitter I know Twitter was
down yeah it's down
oh man this is not a good look for you
boy Elon
it caught me completely off guard
yeah because I was looking in the DM I
was like damn why are you saying the DM
um it won't be
um I was working like a video at a piece
of
POS it wasn't it doesn't um
or what does it refresh yeah yeah it's
not refreshing yeah I'm like damn
took the uh DMS offline because they was
using his own GM against him right
I still haven't played Splatoon three
um
I can play one two or three and I ain't
gonna play Four whenever
games
once I found out that you was a squid
head did you sliding and then some ink I
was like now we're good with this one
it looks dope it looked like a old
Dreamcast game it looked fun
is having issues too because it wouldn't
that's the first time I've ever sent
invites to guest links and we got you
guys cameras wasn't showing up you
couldn't hear me but I could hear you
well maybe that that thing that was
going on with that balloon up in the sky
now you'll find out why you should have
shot it down
oh oh not know what you're talking about
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know you don't
say too much they watching it yeah man
you want to say two months
oh a shadow band for no reason
able spring 2023. was that a DLC addict
I don't know all these stuff look like
DLC I saw Splatoon and I just like dozed
off
oh man pay attention to anything that's
not what we're paying attention to
you're not gonna show Hardware
[Applause]
just a little bit does it look bad like
tell me honestly I try to make it not
only good to me I stretched it like on
each side like equally so it wouldn't
make one side look worse oh bro
[Music]
oh you're stretching it on each side
I want to watch the program bro
hey show me your skates
[Laughter]
[Music]
what do you guys hoping gets announced
what are you talking about this show I
just want Zelda man I want like a like I
want to see him
that's what I want to announce yeah
that's what I want to know you know how
they held like Mario 64 hostage they can
do that just give me the option to buy
it I don't care if you go to Austin
somebody said they're gonna show a Mario
game and I was like 99.
I said they're gonna probably show you
Zelda yeah that probably show them oh
illusion Island wait a second and Goofy
I'm good I'm good why your man look like
that though what do you mean and save
the mistakes
what's that Woody Woodpecker oh is that
Donald Duck who the hell is Donald Duck
it looked like Woody Woodpecker for a
second cat red face for a second I don't
know what the hell is going on every
nook and crap
but we know for a fact that all right
here we go that look all right yeah dude
that looks pretty good bro I'm a fan of
the Castle of Illusion and stuff like
that here's to open new space this looks
pretty good
what's the split screen thing characters
personality probably two player maybe
yeah maybe just maybe maybe oh look at
that four people
you know what it looked like it reminds
me of when I first saw Rayman
oh wait man that was incredible first
time I was yeah that looked incredible
engage just came out three days ago and
they're already trying to tell you yes
that's the only way I'll buy it
it's a good game though
you beat it already yeah I got a review
on the channel
only games only like a uh like a couple
hours long no this this game took me
almost 40 hours to be that's a couple
hours for you
you see what he drinking that's exactly
what he'd be drinking we'd be playing
them games eating a Mexican pizza left
for Taco Bell
Mexican pizza here thank you
you wake up three days later
wake up I never went to bed
the game told him he completed it
challenge news
hey I was the guy in the chat Harry show
some respect this time I'm really like
an Xbox showcase all these cartoony
games show some bad respect Harry
show respect for your market leader
the greatest console ever made I also
everything in the world you better shut
up
the market leader they say figures they
don't care about no FTC they don't care
about no cm
[Music]
you
don't need to play one game
it's me and now that I have a uh a
Nintendo contact I'm hoping to get a
review code for this yo traveler too
which
which yeah skip the next box
oh look at Mario
look at Mario hey Nintendo switch Mario
it's called bring your son to work day
so what my son got a mustache
they just getting this game damn I want
this PS2 game yeah
what if your son Mario wanted to play
God of War what are you going to tell
them
[Applause]
combine the powers
I will be saying these people be
tripping when they want like 60 70 bucks
for these type of games in battle
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know
I don't have a problem with seven dollar
games from the PS5 and Xbox series but
the switch that's been out since 2017.
come on
[Laughter]
[Music]
illustrations are included
look at this game right what the hell is
this oh man you're a tactical
dollars
Max Sammy and more and two full-story
campaigns
directions
good over here
on Nintendo
fistful so that's a Swiss game or the DS
game that they're rebooting for the
switch probably both one of them
um
oh here we go oh here we go what's this
right here
all Kirby's deals
yeah
everybody
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
that's right what the hell does that
says
oh so this is a spin-off in like
something in the curb Universe yeah
[Music]
this dude don't put nothing in his mouth
increase his attack range
[Music]
in the market
yeah this actually looks all right cftc
if you play good games you have to worry
about one game that's mysterious realm
together
oh four players this is the thing Powers
that's cool they had Co-op first party
games
[Music]
gave him light bulbs
this game actually looks pretty good
though seriously oh yeah after today's
shop
ly arranged demo with celeb stages
[Laughter]
February 24th let's get it we hope
you're looking forward
in Kirby's
returns man the games be dropping pretty
soon yup and Microsoft is trying to
accomplish I like that yeah
well what are they about to do are they
about to announce a Game Boy emulator on
the switch
here we go boy games are being added to
Nintendo switch online
I'm good
yes
let's get adding some culture
um
no you got to pay for this we need a
margarita
[Music]
I want to know when the uh one thing I
will uh stream is the uh the old Pokemon
Stadium games yo guys check it out we're
gonna have attic play this Tetris the
legend so we're gonna have that as a tip
yeah
baby to escape and the old school I
remember getting this yeah you remember
getting that me back
that wasn't even in English
[Laughter]
stop
I had that one too oh Mario
games
Kirby's debut title what is that uh the
Virtual Boy
oh that Wario game I went blind playing
it well they have five games yeah five
good games
these cartridges are so cute
we got r b AKA The Underground game up
with the five dollars Nintendo finally
adds Game Boy games to back and pack
five years after my smartphone
gaming throw them in the bushes
he's a panel member of WB I will I will
say this is a big a big
features that they're adding to their
online service
do you think do you think it's wrong
that they don't offer you the ability to
buy these though play 38. they gotta
know how to milk you later
guys
I guess this is cool uh Warrior
Xbox is like we're gonna give you all
the way back to the original Xbox and
selective games no additional charge to
this Library the title comes up like
we're gonna give you this at a
subscription service for all of the
charges
the truth
you can handle the truth
expansion pack wow that's right
[Music]
giving you fomo on your face
[Laughter]
that's a black switch let's look forward
to more information about Nintendo hold
on hold on go back here he had a black
switch with white handles dungeon pack
in the future
let's see a few more headlines
remastered
huh this has been this has been rumored
for a while
that's the one that's not from the
GameCube yeah okay good Metro this is oh
this is this is Nintendo showing their
butt right now listen
I don't care about any of this but I can
tell that a Nintendo fan would love this
show I know I'm re-upping my son's uh
Whatchamacallit his online
around
I'll be playing this I said uh
I'll be playing this
hey look no I remember this
I had a GameCube I think I think this is
what really put Metroid on on a higher
level was this game yeah this is the one
I think he's smoking Ripley
nah it ain't nobody it is
just admit it it's the way
bro it's not better than Super Metro
that's actually pretty cool I'm gonna
give them cradle credits without
switching look good
from the perspective oh yeah they just
High resident up and they bring it back
with that because they came out what 20
something years ago
it came out 20 years ago people want
this they didn't look for Titanfall but
they want this oh my God
I don't like Mario
hell yeah yeah I give them credit that
always creeped me out when they uh when
the Metro is get on top of your Dome
like faster adds new tool stick controls
a digital version later launches today
all right
that's the 10 to low you guys want a
shadow drop something okay okay
that's how the market leader do it this
Spirit haunting him you know I'm pissing
off the PlayStation dude they think they
the blocking leader
[Laughter]
this is persona no this is important
with post cognition that's what my eyes
look like
I believe it do
what are you smoking no he don't smoke
anything he's drinking and he's playing
games
it's crazy
spot the inconsistencies
what's the matter you don't have a Mario
in your house
I got some Mario you sit there you hold
this down originally released on the
Nintendo GameCube system is coming to
Nintendo switch after a long and
peaceful era on the floating islands
above Earth the Empire's conspiracy
looms closer as Spirits I know one thing
if you love these RPGs these RPGs bro
definitely got you covered yeah
there's so many of them
we're already missing out on something
else
everything yeah some guys telling us
about this channel
[Laughter]
oh man hopefully we get to see breath in
a while
ridiculous
yeah put your headset on top of me I'll
talk like he's listening
yo man the show's getting kind of crap
now
it's only 40 minutes right so we got
what three minutes
we got three minutes left so you got one
more announcement bro
[Laughter]
[Music]
some [__]
who's these eyes with the Bland eyes
here we go big Journey the game
Fantasy Life
the girl who steals time
shut up man
[Music]
what is this bro oh it looks nice
they're not showing you that oh is Zelda
show me
um
that look
that look dope let me hitting the
corners too hard
oh they're selling GameCube games they
see you playing catch me riding dirty
catch me
you see me
my voice
expansion pack members can enjoy this
deal here it is
that over
games
all right here they go
Lion King maybe they'll come back maybe
one more at the end
yo I'm not gonna lie
that Mahjong Studios with the with the
Whatchamacallit Minecraft
is getting that money son Microsoft is
getting that cash
game
[Music]
black and white
it's King an attic
us
oh Mega Man what is this Mega Man
Pokemon
the name of that game is have a nice
death that's a pretty dope name for a
game yeah
they can't run the show so they're
getting that game yo this game right
here this game looks good
Facebook
yeah but they can't get MLB to show but
they got this though they got that
oh what's this this number that's on
Xbox already that dream like game that's
my Xbox games
[Music]
[Applause]
here we go here we go thank you Final
Fantasy that's so far
full Dragon here we go here we go please
take a look last thing
one more thing
oh everyone be quiet
[Music]
breathe guys breathe I will not be held
responsible for what happens to you this
is
the system
oh [__] this is it
somebody said it's a new Donkey Kong
[Laughter]
hey get your hand off my face my legs
damn
money on you Zelda I gotta hit Jay
record that cat give my cat Zelda told
you
we will win we will win
if you thought the sales of that DLC was
something wait till you see this
yeah this is the game of the year right
here so don't put out nothing else
that's true buddy ah yo guys
shout out to Nintendo
come on tell us a little bit more
another good year isn't that right Mario
fantastic
[Music]
bless you bless you Eric pockets
they are on DMT that game looks amazing
it's lit let's say yo they stole the
thing from Nuts and Bolts from um I saw
that album yeah
yeah
that's how you do it
that's how you close a direct
fifth twelfth of May cash boys
ah I think I should send them my money
now
yep that was The Legend of Zelda whose
credit card just swiping
it does look in addition to this
Nintendo tried to shut up I mean um
Twitter so nobody can talk about it
today
we don't even use the internet you are
looking forward
oh yes you best believe I'm getting that
meboat for watching we outside it's like
the amiibos as well hell yeah
how many have you got all of them
why are you worrying about my pockets
you're trying to have people rob me you
know they kill people for me both son
I have not collected any of us this this
can poke your eye out I'll hit you with
a Thunder Punch
such a kid what do you think of that
show I thought it was dope
you think I can't do a multiple things
at one time man listen
I have children
I thought it was a good show I mean for
a fan like a guy like me that's not a
fan on Nintendo at all I'm sure Nintendo
fans loved it I give it a 8 out of 10. I
I liked um well I like Metroid style
that's a big one Shadow drop remaster so
dust off the switch where the hell is it
you must have been sitting here since
the last um Zelda
and we about to have some fun I still
got two of these to give away they stop
selling these this is like this is
the one that came out with the the Zelda
like well yeah that's what I got I got
that one it's been through it's like
duct tape uh holding the back of it oh I
see it oh goodness not not mine mine if
you look at them if you look at this
hey
guys don't you love this guy y'all don't
know gaming dude 10 out of 10 just
because like you said eight out of 10.
is that serious
Lord Metroid with the two dollar Super
Chat thank you so much brother Metro
Prime remastered looks amazing nine out
of ten yo I feel you
um as a Nintendo fan as a Nintendo fan
you probably walked away from that
talking about 10 out of 10 be honest
with you yeah yeah
as a Nintendo player eight eight I give
it an eight I mean they showed the okay
so the shadow drop is a big one uh they
showed Zelda at the end looks great
uh what else they showed uh Minecraft
Legends they showed that black and white
game
um that looked good they showed um
the death game uh all they Platformers
look fantastic
I'm giving it a six out of 10.
oh
yeah I'm waiting for me man it just
wasn't for me like six uh ten from hey
hey so I see so I'll see a few guys
taking shots that red Falls they redfall
the Dead
okay well it releases after redfall
though right like a week after yeah
probably so it doesn't matter um you're
talking about the market leader versus
and and dropping probably one of the
most anticipated games of this
generation
all right and you worrying about redfall
stop acting like redfull was a contender
for the throne or something right there
comparing it to Nintendo look in the
Champions it's a few guys saying redfall
is dead
we got 206 people in the chat go ahead
uh hit that like button and share this
song Oh I need to I need to do time
stamps before I get screamed up yo man
you got the timestamps ready at it no
you got you got the people saying you
know that this game uh is going to kill
uh redfall
you know if Floyd get some good shots in
there but come on now
once Mike bite his ears over what Philly
shell is not gonna help against Tyson
all right Tyson misses but that's fine
but Philly shell is not good it's not
gonna work over that because a volume
beats the Philly show a shout out to
Killian brown with the two dollar Super
Chat Nintendo dropped that whole show
addict uh attic tripping yeah yo y'all
got different opinions bro you know that
right yeah but it's fine you know attic
sees it in one way but I can tell you
this I think it's gonna stream all those
games no I'm not
it's not just addict anymore we have a
patreon terror forcing any lower to play
anything okay cool I'm down with it um
you know that means I can go put money
down and have you play stuff you don't
want to play
ain't that right Marriott
they can tell you to play a game you
don't want to play yeah that's a sick
idea you know what attic just finished
playing Punch Out Super Punch Out
no that was for selling um Volari
pillows okay
so we got to get that patreon he's like
what was Zelda like Zelda looked like
DLC though all right so what's that Lord
Lord Metroid with the two dollar super
tears of the kingdom is super
sugary Robinson yo I'm not gonna lie I
agree with you
it is Sugar Ray Robinson quality it is
um this probably is going to be one of
the most anticipated games of Our
Generation and to say otherwise is is is
is a lie it definitely is and anybody
that showed up to this direct wanted to
see that game so without further ado
I give you the man of the hour too sweet
to be sour all right so let's move on to
the patreon thing real quick so we do
have someone uh I picked uh a question
related to Nintendo every Oprah Mario
game gets a new game mechanic they give
your boy a water hose and sunshine and
he could toss a hat and odyssey what new
game mechanics would you like to see in
the next Mario game it's not the right
question huh you need to take hard drugs
what are you doing you can't think of
that think about the the whole concept
how are we gonna go how are we going to
come up with something where a hat takes
over a mechanic it's not even about the
Hat mechanic in Mario it's all about the
other stuff The Possession design
that's that's a dope idea but also y'all
forgetting the type when they got suits
that they gave them different properties
right the frog suit the Beast I know man
that's the cat suit you know they they
always innovate so I think this time
they to have some magic shoes magic
shoes all right so don't they are gonna
have a magic shoes they did a hat they
did a costume
so a magic shoes you can have water
shoes you can have fire shoes you can
have metal yeah
so is traviso is a thing yeah if you
like traversal is where people are
focusing on Platformers and also on
Shooters
um so you could say like a traversalm
actually that's a good child you see but
then you need another concert other than
oh it confirmed Zelda is 70 in the
Nintendo store right now we're gonna go
get that
um that's what the market leader does
all right hey guys tell me what that
Prime remake is tell me what that Prime
remaster is hold on we got random
citizen remember for six months Lord
bronze whether it's Zelda or red four
game is a gonna game that's on God
but what I am happy for
is the market leader dropped the show
right after dropping their financials
and telling you exactly how much they
showed and it came with a good show and
it gave you something to look forward to
at least for the next six months right
that was the next six months type of
thing um yeah it seemed like it yeah
all that stuff is going to be in your
hands before the summertime
what is
Jabari tweet and he says I hope tears
the kingdom supports HDMI 2.1 vrr 120
hertz Ray tracing fast loading 4K 30 or
1440 over 60 a redumble and adaptive
triggers if I'm going to pay 17 for that
you paid 70 For Worse
they're broken yeah but Twitter looks to
be back up
[Laughter]
you guys be saying that
that evil laugh man I can't take you
seriously with that Zelda in front of
you like that why not
why not you never play with toys as a
child
look at look at how ridiculous he'd be
looking right now I look fantastic I
look like a Toys R Us kid they ain't
letting it go yeah stop it stop it
all right all right all right so yeah
let's just go around the room man one
out of ten or King obviously one out of
ten no no one out of ten what is your
ranking guys go for nine oh I mean eight
oh God sorry
ah Evan a what
why do you just say six then
why you can't be generous only because
it's so hard to pull away Zelda uh from
it but the Zelda showed off well
Zelda and Metroid but you've got Metroid
in a different guys you didn't get
Metroid four gameplay you got Metroid
remasters and it drops today so when I
sit there and think about it I'm like uh
six is a bit lower man seven is pretty
good and like you guys said that I was
getting Pikmin it's not for me but other
people like it didn't like all the
expansion packs don't like the fact that
the Game Boy stream thing but still
that's back on part that's big still in
some way King stop it stop
it I'm done with this kid
yo you
know screenshot
part right now
screenshot that it posted on to uh
post it on Twitter right there we
screenshot that post that on Twitter
oh my God someone do it take a picture
post it on Twitter
[Laughter]
yeah so I mean
I give it a six like I said there wasn't
really a whole lot even Zelda didn't
really like Captivate me too much I felt
like they just kind of showed us stuff
we already knew like it wasn't didn't
feel like a new type of trailer it's
just like we're gonna show you what you
already expect this game to fill and
play like like
I get it I would have preferred like a
maduro's mask or something where you uh
re-release but
King come on man
this is on my screen and this is my big
brother right here a link
he doesn't talk too much
a pause today
[Music]
we got a two dollar super trap from
Randy G the only game I'm interested in
is Metroid
good you're purchasing
[Laughter]
[Music]
did you take any of that advanced EG
stuff no I did not no Focus you just no
not at all only thing I focus on is
winning npds in that month
count the numbers and stuff you know
you can't you cannot stop it
man yeah so I mean that's pretty much
how it is we'll go ahead and move on to
uh uh the the pre uh Nintendo stuff I
mean can you said you want to talk about
the numbers didn't you briefly yes
um
can I talk to King and not link
but here's my voicemail
it's just you don't want to give him his
flowers man dudes act like we don't show
Nintendo love I'm showing them more love
than anything I guess oh hold on we got
uh
PC Inlet for the rest king
that Nintendo is is showing you you
don't need to have the most powerful
console
you don't need to have uh the games that
runs at the highest resolution you don't
need to have games that's taken
advantage of all advanced Tech and your
television and all that other stuff it
all boils down to games right and it all
boils down to staying true to their
brand and giving their core fans exactly
what they're looking for and keep
feeding that fire so I don't know what
to say I this the switch is a runaway
hit it's the greatest console in
existence right now to be honest with
you as far as numbers go and dudes got
to get used to the fact that I'm sorry
but the truth of the matter is they are
the market leader right numbers dictated
sales dictated and I I honestly don't
see this year slowing down from them
it's very hard to put out a new console
when the existing console is selling
like gangbusters for no absolute reason
but they're going to continue to do what
they're doing and I'm going to continue
to buy so Zelda will stay on my screen
May oh God oh God
I'm not even repeat that hold on all
right so we got a two dollars remember
with the two dollar super tax that's
double look dope see
let's put respect on Zelda mean no yeah
I can't take him seriously he's got the
Xbox logo on his chest that's his next
destination
from slow-mo backslap Saul EV uh saw
awesome games that will run great on the
steam deck yeah he's got a point there a
lot of those probably gonna run on the
steamboat
I just I would prefer a little bit more
of games that interest me uh but you
know I got the game I wanted which was
kind of Fire Emblem so
Splatoon I actually played Splatoon I
don't mind Splatoon I actually played
Splatoon too oh respect on splatoon's
name
all right let's let's move on to
I'm sure you guys saw last week you know
rainfall always being online you know do
you guys think that that's like an issue
and they say no no geez you said that
mad fast isn't Hogwarts Legacy the exact
same no
or something and then after that you can
play it offline I believe oh you can
okay but but at first it was online it
wasn't that well you need a patch like
the majority of the games you need to
have that DRM authenticate because this
is fake outrage man it's 2023 people
still crying man they know how many
games has this
the only issue I have is they they were
heavily marketing there at the end
that it was a single player game and to
me if you really Market single player
format games they'd be able to play it
offline
that that's that's the only Knack I have
like I get it it's not a problem to me
listen this is not an Xbox thing it's
listen this is not an Xbox thing to me
this is a
a fake outrage thing if a place I didn't
care about the gtas I don't care bro
yeah we might talk a little Trash here
and only because they talk trash you
know so why not fast back I care about
this stuff bro if our internet goes now
we're screwed anyway right yeah that's
true it's true bro so we're always
online Twitter went down for like three
minutes and we just shout ourselves like
this is a my point there's my but see
that's the that's the whole thing we've
been under online life for forever
ever since you got your cell phone in
the online life right since you you you
you started Banking online you've been
in an online life the only people that
this is affecting is those dudes that
want to be off the grid
so yeah
anyway you know don't worry about our
stuff that's about the point there I'm
just I'm just tired of it oh man I was
like because I could have sworn
Hardwoods Lexie had the same situation
but I guess not it was um somebody
pulled my coat to it and said it was
just a first patch then after you
download the first patch and then you
know then it's okay but okay it's it's
neither here nor there if you're living
in any modern household yeah we know for
a fact there's two things you do not let
go out in your house
the lights and the Wi-Fi
and if the lights go out all of us go
out anyway that's it right so yeah make
make sure the lights is painful and then
make sure the Wi-Fi is paid for the
worst thing that you can do is go inside
your house see I live in a modern house
where I got cameras all around my house
you know
um door from from The Ring doorbell to
the cameras that's inside the house to
to the to the door locks I got special
locks that use the Wi-Fi you know you
use your thumb print or authenticates
you know um my cell phone so it's
different things that needs to be online
so if my console is online it doesn't
bother me because it's just par for the
course this is what being in a digital
ERA this is what comes with it now
people being upset with a game being
always online let's say this and I'm
going to keep it 100. a game that's
modeled around our online always online
premise has the ability to adapt and
change on the Fly
again but
it's the reason to sell you things you
got to take a fortnight and to look at
it right but they haven't announced that
they haven't announced that the the
whole reason for the online activities
well maybe the online and remember they
said that everybody could be across the
world doing their own thing right drop
in and drop out multiplayer right so
remember the tethering thing we don't
know how far the tethering thing goes
maybe it goes extra far now
of course because nobody's answering
these questions so it's left up to us to
make assumptions to make accusations and
to come up to our own uh deductions
because they're not really answering the
hard questions to a game that they want
everybody to play
yeah so that's what we're doing really
we make such a big deal about it yes
it's like a little bit of an L just take
the L it's like no one cares but they're
not doing it now they don't want to take
it though they're like no I I refuse to
take that please thank you
but here's the L but no isn't your cell
phone online get it away from me
listen pick your L back thank you yes
all I'm saying all I'm saying and I'm
Gonna Keep it quick all I'm saying is
that this is the times that we live in
bro it's like like Kingdom say
everything is digital like I mean it's
the times we live in I don't know why
one game
um that has Co-op you know but the
single player mode if it's not connected
online you can't play okay listen 2K
you obviously can play single player you
can play online
um bro that boy won't work at all if
it's not connected to the internet yeah
records like we are watching this online
well obviously we're watching this so
why are you saying that let's chat
crackhead it's like oh yeah let me grab
the Super Chat real quick called we with
the five dollar super chat some people
whining whining by digital games PSN
went down for like four hours yesterday
and nobody could play anything even
offline games
but you won't hear the outcry I think
people confuse people confuse like
us sharing libraries and people get that
confused with truly not being able to
play online games like because when Xbox
goes down
people oh yeah always if you're sharing
a digital library with someone that that
means everything's down no it just means
that you could only play the stuff to
the person you're sharing a digital
library with bought you can't buy
anything on yours because your
yeah because when you sign in you access
the license and the games that you
bought through your online kind of like
a DRM kind of situation but if you make
your console home you could play all the
games you bought you just won't have
access to the game
yeah that's true that's okay
I'm getting the better deal there
I gave him [__] with my son so I don't
get the best the best out of the day he
get the best for me though it's almost
said okay full price it's almost said
the only host getting progress is co-op
in my uh only issue I feel that um I do
think that oh I don't like that yeah
that should have been fixed we in age
it'd be different if like other
companies haven't done it but it's like
we've seen Borderlands there's a lot of
games
what it's like like he's having a
thought bubble oh yeah a shadow or
something
it was like I'm like this dude is
thinking hard as hell oh yeah
I'm thinking right now
that's dope as hell someone said that's
the ray tracing
so do you think that that's something
that they you put that on there you put
the always online do you think those are
gonna hurt red fault dramatically or
just gonna be something people complain
about but ultimately still play even
beat the game I'm still dying on the
rage racing
um I can answer that for you
the majority of people that's going to
play this in Game Pass
Game Pass is always online
they're not going to have a problem
about it so the only people that's
crying and [__] in the moaning about it
is people that don't have Game Pass so
they want to point out the deficiencies
of another product that they don't
actually own a patron
but the people that actually own and
Patron Game Pass is not going to have a
problem with it because Game Pass is
online always yeah so exactly it's like
it's always online you're buying on game
pause however's going to be playing game
pause but luckily and let's be real most
people are playing this Co-op this is a
co-op game they give you a buffer
playing a co-op yeah you can't even have
other Heroes with you when you're
playing single player mechanically they
designed it as Co-op you use uh the
purple chicks thing and you bounce up
jump
yes you get you get a literal buff
called the trust buff where the four
characters
just listen to it right just listen to
it you're gonna get a trust buff just
listen to it
and they have in unique dialogue lines
if you use the certain characters that
means they want you to pick different
ones yes then you get the trust buff
because they'll have different dialogue
lines the whole game is made and you
kind of get that in single player you're
not gonna hear any dialogue between the
characters just you like come on that's
the whole game is made for Co-Op I said
this is my video yeah it's so obvious
but they don't but for some reason you
know why it's because their legacy is
all single player like death Loop yes
all of Dishonored and they feel a little
bit strange venturing out because
they're trying to hold up we are still
single player they have to do that they
were forced to do that because of their
legacy but in this case they didn't want
to do a single player in my opinion they
want to do a full play co-op like a PC
hardcore and the hardcore fan base of
that the studio so Arcane Austin will
say Dishonored pray and then boom you go
to Microsoft and you make a or play a
co-op game that's why but and that's
what I'm telling you play cohub and all
this stupid online anything makes no
difference the game is an online co-op
game that's how you should treat it
that's the best way to play this game
guarantee you the reviews the single
player is just an afterthought
in your opinion the single player is the
Sub sub this is a sub Quality Service
you're not getting there for the reward
and not getting the experience for the
full Squad I mean the game was marketed
as the full dialogue the CGI trailer
that they showed you two years ago is
literally them speaking and you don't
get to hear any of that dynamic and you
don't get the buff and it's just like
come on uh
yo I got to play with that buff man
exactly
if you're playing red four you gotta
have that trust buff so yeah and if
someone comes in and picks the same
characters as yours like yo man change
that so we can get it that's right yeah
nobody's wearing the same sneakers do
you guys like when they force you to
play a different character like they
just won't let you play with duplicate
yes
yeah I like that I like that that's
Confessor man just like simple yeah
four clones when you play Apex Legends
it changes up who can put like who picks
first and stuff and yeah sometimes I'll
sit there and I'll go third I'm like
Dave about to pick anyone I want to pick
like it's just like tactile what's funny
is like everyone now it'll be a timer
going off of the first two people so the
first one will pick something like I
think I got it I got it and the second
dude picture did you want to I was like
I just hate my squad straight away from
the get-go because they just both of
them picked both of my first dude pigs
oh yeah you're a huge Apex dude yeah how
did you feel about that um the TitanFall
thing that got canceled oh man I'm a
huge Titanfall guy as well man
um Titanfall that's sad so sad man but
the thing is with Vincent pillow it's
weird like the decision would have been
EA it would have been him and if he
didn't think it's good good enough he
would call it the guy has too much
respect EA cannot come up to him and say
cancel that Titanfall game it means he
canceled it there's no way he would tell
him to put his middle finger at their
faces he does it on Twitter he doesn't
Twitter when EA did something he was
like what the hell is this nonsense this
guy this employer quote tweeted it what
was it chat it was that ad isn't it or
something stupid he's like this is
stupid but on that EA official tweet I'm
mad man that guy has respected
I didn't have a chance to talk to
somebody that you know actually plays
Apex a lot and I know you do because you
you've sunk tons of cash in there so and
this kind of directly affects you so I
really wanted to know your opinion on it
to be honest with you I appreciate it no
that's just that's what it is I mean
paying for we are dying for Titanfall I
would sacrifice so many games for
Titanfall three but it has to be a good
game and they're good questions around
it do you still stick with the source
engine The Source engine's old now and
like fine but the feel is really
important and a lot of people say
Titanfall one's a multiplayer was really
good good so it's like
before if you're going to get it right
that's it like if you can't get it right
then fine and to be honest Gamers also a
bit apathetic to town fall too let's be
honest everyone says oh no but it
dropped between Battlefield and Call of
Duty well what about now you can still a
good game how many people have played it
how many Prestige are you I'm 10 to
prestige or like how did people play it
like no that was my point it takes ages
did you feel away with the whole
Titanfall cancellation uh the side game
thing with the Apex
um well I'm like this I you know stuff
happens
for whatever reason
um Vincent Paulo you know he seems to
have the Midas touch over there yeah so
um if he's making that decision which
I'm pretty sure it is because then they
promote him recently and he's working he
used to head over Battlefield yeah yeah
um yeah I mean I I think we're in the
times where these companies are really
being careful with like they're picking
the tools and what to develop because
they don't want
these games to like Titanfall 2
unfortunately as good as the game as it
was it flopped so I think that they're
really being
really picky with what they decide to go
like move forward with financially
financially because they're doing it
yeah everybody's doing it bro yeah
everybody's doing it yeah I mean this
isn't the PS2 Xbox generation anymore
these games are expensive they take a
lot of Manpower they take a lot of time
and they're really picking and choosing
like uh we have to sacrifice something
what should we sacrifice we don't want
to sacrifice this you know what this
this gotta go or whatever yeah yeah but
I don't think they sacrificed it I think
what they've done is they've said parked
it to one side because he's stretched so
thin he's working on Battlefield okay so
you said it's like he's not on the back
burner like they're postponing it like
they're gonna go back to eventually you
think but that's not yeah that's what
the TitanFall Community is hoping and it
makes sense don't Vince needs to laser
focus on Titanfall that game is Big
that's the same thing I thought about
the you know the Coalition games that
they uh they show I think they you know
just put it to the side because
financially right now you got to start
looking at uh all the layoffs and stuff
that is going to happen this year all
the way through this year probably up
until you know 2025 to be honest with
you and you know how they deal with that
and how they guide itself out of this
financial crisis and you have to be
profitable right yeah so being
profitable you can't really take too
many gambles on unknown IPS or IPS that
didn't perform how they supposed to
perform or how you thought they would
have performed in the marketplace so
this is not the time for it but we did a
ton of direct stuff uh addict what was
your score for the show again six out of
ten six out of ten dirt just go for the
show
you're talking about the CMAs
I'm gonna I'm gonna say
eight out of ten eight out of ten yeah
yeah I'll give it eight as well how do
you guys feel about Zelda being a 70
title oh no that's something we can talk
about it's worth it yeah
all of us are gonna pay it yeah I think
there's a difference between saying
we're gonna pay it in like
it would be different if I felt like
they're they were just doing it for
Zelda because they know they can get it
from Zelda but I feel like they're just
gonna massive roll this out to
everything else like and and to me it's
like at this point are we going to be 70
70 for every Nintendo game when yeah
the sister came out in 2017 dude so
that's that's my issue with the attic I
have no problems they're just raising it
to raise it like and this was the new if
this was the new Switch I would get it
yeah at least right now we can look at
something like you know the Xbox One and
the Xbox series X
16 59.99 169.99 so you could see why
they did the 10 jump sure it still makes
no sense why they had to do it but I
could kind of get behind it a little bit
more but if you think about it we're
probably gonna be paying 70 for for a
system that was made in 2017 for 900p to
720.
are you still feeling guilty for partner
I mean clearly I'm still gonna get it
that's not the issue the issue is just
like Nintendo
they know they got a product that that
is not going to hit them back like
please stop
I can laugh at everybody because they're
gonna sit there play zeld is 70 but
you're gonna copy
gaming Forte with a five dollar super
check it's six out of ten did you sleep
and miss the show
I'm paying more for Zelda because I'm
getting the collector's position don't
let uh don't let a Zelda OLED drop
facts well I mean I got this thing that
this thing will probably blow up at this
point playing a Zelda game like well I
got the same one right there
mine is gonna be on this side right
there so so you said you gave it a what
out of uh out of ten seven
I'm very towards about a seven I'll
stick to the seven all right so you're
giving it a seven I thought it was
because I mean a great show
um you know we can clown on Nintendo and
Prime is 40 bucks
you could tell they Shadow dropped that
just because it's like a reactionary
thing from Microsoft because they said
you know the physical it's it's like
they had a meeting like the physical
versions when's the last time you saw
something released digitally before
physically
something especially his biggest Prime
they're like look it's like they had a
meeting like can we get this out by this
day oh you know we we can get it out by
the end of February what about this
direct we we can do the digital version
I haven't seen them do that before name
one example that I've never seen anyone
do that before well what I do like is
we are seeing Petty Nintendo
this is petty Nintendo check it out
Sony put out the numbers of God of War
Nintendo said hold my beer
Hi-Fi Rush came out with a shadow drop
for 40 bucks Nintendo said hold my bear
I like this Nintendo they cut you deep
and they cut you fast they cut you to
the quick seventy dollars we will not be
out priced by anyone
do what you gonna buy why cause Nintendo
put it now baby and you're gonna buy it
on Old Hardware they've always said
it's been Nintendo this is Nintendo
being Nintendo hey guys but but hold on
can we be honest though yeah
nobody's gonna complain about this seven
dollars we're gonna buy it we're buying
it I know I know you guys are buying it
because you guys are fans but Nintendo
fans won't complain they'll suck up no
see that's what I'm saying like like car
key just said in the chat
it will make sense if this was on the
new Nintendo like the new Nintendo
switch or whatever it is
real quick five dollars even Nintendo is
going 70. I wish they had waited until
the Next Gen Con until let's hope tears
is more optimized than breath of the
wild maybe 60 frames docked doubt yeah
even that you're not gonna get Nintendo
you're thinking frames I can't guarantee
that you're not gonna get 60 frames and
you know what they're going to do
they're going to drop a uh tears of the
Kingdom switch with that thing too
uh THX one one three eight eShop shows
Kirby 59.99 Metroid 39.99 uh Pikmin
Force 59.99 Zelda tiers 69.99 Nintendo
pricing accordingly just like Microsoft
okay
maybe maybe he's right T.A text is right
because the big one is Pikmin and that's
still 60 and Kirby is 60. yep Pikmin 4
is coming out right or is it out already
see what do you even like what do you
argue that that would make it worse
though because they're charging ten
dollars more just because they know they
can like that's clearly what they're
doing because they know they're here
because look okay let me say that's
great with Xbox and PlayStation and
those third-party games you know the the
budgets of these games are going up
right you know we still want the the big
AAA game so the buzzers are going up
this is still the Nintendo switch that
yeah budget come on bro that buzzing
isn't going up not enough
so they're doing it because they can
maybe it took some time to build that
flying little kite thing wherever he was
like hoverboard oh yeah or like the uh a
nursing boats uh truck that he was in yo
listen man y'all gonna stop starting on
Zelda acting like Zelda don't command a
70 you got a lot of games out there
that's getting a 70 dollar guap and
Zelda demands it it's okay man if the
beautiful girl come to the club man you
buy that drink stop playing man you know
but you've been buying a lot of drinks
for these ducks out here let them ducks
live let them do them but this one right
here you know she's showing off the best
she the best one in the club
I just look she's wearing clothes that
are a little bit sold but then I guess
to me I guess to me it looks way worse
because it's looking like they're not
doing it because they feel like their
products are worth it they feel like
they're doing it because you know what
we can't get this for Kirby we'll get a
little backlashing you know a little bit
of sales last week
because Kirby isn't not a Mainline Kirby
game that's a spin-off
yeah it wasn't a main line a Mario game
there are we expecting all of them to be
17 then right and no I wasn't expecting
that I was expecting see Nintendo's
pricing accordingly you want to get the
new product this is the product
or just Zelda are you saying oh so you
thinking the next games won't adopt to
70 from Nintendo the Wario rabbits be
seventy dollars
no no is it from now on maybe the only
way they can style this is like from now
on we're doing 70 because Microsoft's
just did a new term so whoa I say this
right
we haven't heard about layoffs in
Nintendo and we're pretty sure that DJ
have layoffs
We're Not Gonna Act Like uh this is not
affecting everybody this is affecting
everybody we're going to stop acting
like this is not really a thing it's a
real thing but accordingly layoffs no
I'm talking about the economic downturn
you know you don't want to see the r
words you know but the r word is real
it's real you know it's physical you go
to the store right now it's physical but
yeah but Nintendo priced it accordingly
everybody walked in here and did not
think Zelda was going to be 60 bucks I
didn't I knew it was going to be 69.95
all right uh but that uh Kirby is priced
accordingly uh the the Whatchamacallit
is priced accordingly all other games is
priced accordingly and I and I think
that they have their finger on the post
of what needs to be done at this moment
now if it was a new Mario game which
they'll probably show later on that
gonna be 72 bro you going You're Gonna
buck up for that 70. it's gonna happen
they're making record profits though yes
sir they should do that
[Laughter]
[Music]
yo so yo let's get up out of here
because I heard food was almost finished
in my house
which I I do want to briefly talk about
this uh Playstation refusing to help
Xbox partly they've extended their uh
their summons like three times
it's not a summer it's a subpoena get
your behind into court bro
you know what happens when you come in
there you can't come in here Big Man on
Campus talking about flexing out God of
water and did all of this and you got
the big record profits you can't say
that and then go in and talk about you
the little duckling they're gonna hurt
you they can't say that you know so when
they say all right you'll come in bring
in your books bring bring books
some dudes don't know who young Gunner
is all right I know what you do but I'm
gonna break it down to people because
they don't know who when I say they got
gunny face yeah YSL is you know that's
that's the room from uh as a rap group
right and they were doing some felonious
things so in the hood no snitching is
the way if you're down with the
felonious stuff you can't snitch on your
homies well they all got rounded up and
everybody in the click snitch right oh
it's one famous dude and he was arm and
armed with the leader he is snitching so
I say PlayStation dudes are not ponies
that is a derogatory term that should
not be used and should be not expressed
anywhere they are Gunnies
[Laughter]
so
right now they subpoenaed them to court
and they thought they were just
testifying the background with the black
you know Shield over them and they get
silhouette
you know but now they got a billion coin
they gotta actually Point them out and
they got to show their taxes
I could just see it like the the the the
you know the black room you just see the
Shadow and look how you feel about that
Jim this is a gym I don't know
[Laughter]
Jim uh Ryan so we were wondering do you
have all of the uh evidence that you
guys will be hurt if XBox bought
activism blizzard Jim Ryan uh you know
you see uh
baby Mama's daughter
hey I think King Dave said it the best
like when they got that first opinion oh
wait wait a minute I thought we was like
you said I thought we was in snitching
no they but they asking for way too much
hey man tell them no and I hope they
just let it go
you know how when creditors call you you
sending a voicemail
you're not even acting I heard they not
even answering Activision phone calls
yeah that's what they said that's what
Bobby Bobby said they're not even answer
it Bobby Colton said this is around the
time of the year we start playing for
the future
and she ghosted me imagine
imagine like they're just not returning
your phone calls what's that they just
make a song about it so I was gonna make
a song about it one day
you see Jim Ryan come up like this he's
like and wipes his mouth off because
wait this is not working anymore
right oh man you see it you see it bro
imagine being like the Video Game Awards
and like Jim was around Phil it feels
like coming up to Jim and Jim's like
just goes in the VIP area that's just
for his people and Phil's like Jim man
let's talk for a second he's like shut
the door don't let him in here
they done did something bad to you when
you're getting in the elevator he seen
you coming he's closing it right he's
like when you press that button real
fast
okay so Microsoft has questions
that they're going to ask them
because this is a Microsoft subpoena
right so they have questions and they
can't lie they're right they can't
because
right so
you're going to be asked about Final
Fantasy do you think they're trying to
delay it long enough to where Microsoft
just gives up on the deal entirely
Microsoft will never give up well you
get what I'm saying like why delay
things yeah if you know you're
eventually gonna be in court why would
you keep trying to delay The subpoena
because because they they were relying
on FTC and the CMA to kill it off before
that hence stalling stalling stalling
and they're stuck they're stuck because
they know the deal look I said it on
Twitter today the deal is going through
it's gonna take a while because there's
no way big business is going to be
curtailed by a regulatory body like this
not just Microsoft's business it's going
to be all other business you're telling
me some of the so anyway I can go on
about that but Sony are stuck they're
desperate and they are scared to even
answer the call Bobby Cottage crazy and
they start trembling like one of Bobby
Bobby's that's that's crazy
anybody in management position or in uh
ownership position to answer a phone
call from somebody that you've been
doing business with yeah right good good
business right somebody that you've been
sending checks and getting checks from
so
um that's that's kind of troublesome you
know at the same time
we see
that the deal is going to go through but
Microsoft had the foresight to tell you
it was going to be a year yeah they did
from that point and everything like
myself I thought it would be done in
November and it wasn't oh yeah
they did say June 2023 from the
beginning from the beginning that's the
12 month plan and they stick with
everything for 12 months for some rare
reason but they know something that we
don't but the only people that still
seem very confident with it and standing
on a square is Microsoft absolutely
Activision
definitely Activision
email today yeah
he was basically telling everyone hey
guys so this deal is basically going
through so I'm going to send you some
emails to accept you yeah
it's going to give you a new Microsoft
hoodies I saw it bro I was like whoa
yeah yeah so I saw Adidas I saw Adidas
said that they shipping out the new
Adida Xbox Adidas to the employees
[Laughter]
the Microsoft if Microsoft really wanted
to be like mad Petty they'd shut off
those azero servers and then when the
team done
they're calling Microsoft support to
figure out what's going on they're like
oh there's a service order here you know
it says Jim has to call Phil
hey yo yo got the phone let's let's
close this out guys we got 316 watching
we only have 120 likes please get those
likes up please share this out uh dirt
where can the people find you at oh of
course man um check out my channel Dirk
Gregory uh you know I host a podcast on
Monday evening's called uh WBZ Xbox
podcast we talk a lot of trash and I say
this every week PlayStation Fanboys you
will not like it and it's you know
hashtag a pony free zone man I'm tired
of you guys Tyler and Chris hard and
everybody popping in yeah
nobody wants to hear it over here so uh
yeah
is that one of those things where he's
telling you not to come just so you'll
come he's really telling you not to come
like if you're gonna cause like issues
in his chat don't go please well my man
gas
um you know and I definitely like you
know to always extend my hand to my man
over there uh got crazy love for you my
dude and I just tell the people where
they can find you at and what you got
going on sir thank you man uh you can
find me on game on daily Saturday show
I've got a video coming out uh Xbox
versus PlayStation the Battle of
exclusives that should be out tomorrow
um and x and C I'm on in cold show for
three more shows then I'm done so you
can but you can see me at the end of
this month three more shows they can see
me there
um yeah on Twitter gazond alien
aily.com the best of class news
aggregation platform that no one uses
uses Wicked it's check it yourself and
think it's crap tell me because you
won't it is that's how good it is
attic talk about what you got going on
talk about what you doing talk about
this guy right here talk about it sir
with the nice good haircut tell me sir
what's going on so um first off I preach
everyone coming through we add up to
like 340 people in here hit that like
button on the way out you know I'm not
giving your shoes back until you hit the
like button I'm just gonna hold them
hostage man some of you have expensive
shoes okay don't mess with me all right
shut up
definitely hit that like button uh uh I
am going to be streaming more on my
twitch channel uh you know I'm streaming
Hogwarts Legacy right now the game is
crazy you know what's funny is they said
you can be bad in that game like you can
eventually start to do like evil stuff
and uh you know right now I at first I
thought I was just going to do that at
the gate right I started seeing these
these teachers and stuff okay maybe I
can't do it to these teachers
so so you know I'm trying to get I'm
trying to get my numbers up my my raking
up man I'm trying to get the some dark
art spells because you know in order to
I have a feeling I'm gonna need some
power and you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
take what the teachers give me and I'm
gonna give it back to them eventually so
I'm thinking about picking that game up
and I'm not a Harry Potter fan
you can find me getting ready to go get
some food yes hell yeah I'm starving an
Atticus
um that's not gonna happen we're out of
here
on Twitter with Twitter is actually
working and uh yeah stop playing around
dirt uh I want y'all all to say uh he's
saying because we got it going now he's
two two two your man have already been
gone by now
the market leader yes
you know what you need to do you need to
put like a voice thing in your uh in
your Zoom thing where it's Mario saying
something and you click it
well yo guys it was great everybody
showed up on a Wednesday for Nintendo
Direct and when you guys say that we
don't show Nintendo love I say look at
this direct and then you know know who
the market leader is
all right go ahead okay and then you can
uh you know we do have a patreon me and
King have been doing a patreon uh on r r
stuff where you can catch our live
reactions to certain animes and stuff
Kings live react and Attack on Titan and
I'm live reacting to chainsaw man uh so
I think I got four sick anime I got four
episodes yeah I got four episodes uh the
first four episodes live reacted so far
King's about to start uh Midway through
the first season of Attack on Titan
we're gonna get some of that on tomorrow
I appreciate it for coming I appreciate
it for coming through and uh you know
and so next week this is uh this is gas
dirt griggity and King well King's gone
but yeah the thing is right here oh bro
yeah I'm sleep it's called nighttime
King you just get letters in night time
King man night time King I appreciate
everything you guys all right everybody
peace out peace
I'm Jim Ryan and I